- Hello.
Hi everybody. Welcome to
my talk or to our talk.
We're doing a joint talk together today
about powering real time applications
with a modernized cache.
My name is Pieter Cailliau,
I'm with Redis now for eight years,
and I lead the product
management team responsible
for the core engine of Redis.
But before we start, I
wanted to ask like, who knows
what Redis is?
Oh, almost literally everybody.
So I was going to explain what it is.
So I'll give you the
very brief what Redis is.
Oh, so sorry about that. Thank you.
Redis is an in-memory data structure store
that is most often used as
a cache, as a session store,
as a message broker, as a
database, as a vector search store
or full text search store.
And we have nowadays about 2.25 million
docker pools per day.
And we actually just crossed 10 billion
docker pools, which is amazing,
on the Open Source version of Redis.
We're voted again by Stack Overflow
as the most loved non-relational database
by the (indistinct) community.
Within my team, we
focus upon three things.
We focus on the core
Redis, Redis Open Source,
and the data structures
that you've all been using.
We focus upon developer experience,
which means client libraries,
visual developer tools,
copilots, Redis Insight.
Maybe some of you have used it.
I see some people nodding.
And we also focus upon
moving data into Redis
and make it easy for you
to move data into Redis.
I'll talk about that later on.
The way I structure the
talk is a talk on evolution.
I think everything that
we did like in the product
is a consequence of how
users were using Redis.
Most often it's users
that were pushing the
boundaries of Redis that
were hitting limitations
of what it could do,
and we tried to find a
better solution for that.
Of course, there will still
be some product announcements
in there, so sometimes
there'll be like a QR code,
which you can use to scan
and look into the product
later on if you would love to.
Because the talk is low on AI,
I've used or asked ChatGPT
to create some images.
They're quite funny, so I
hope it's a bit entertaining.
So at least I can say AI as many times
as all the other talks
that are going on today.
And then lastly, later on I'll
be joined by Heber Scachetti,
which I just learned
is an Italian last name
who is a machine learning
engineer at ifood.
And he will talk you through
how some of the capabilities
that I will show you in Redis
and how they're using that at ifood.
But I wanna start with
the opportunity of Redis.
According to Microsoft, 80%
of the OLTP workloads
on Microsoft SQL Server
are pure read queries.
Oracle claims that for
typical OLTP workloads,
it range between 70 and 90%.
And 90% means that for every right
you make into a relational database,
on average you read the same
unchanged data nine times.
Or the other reverse;
if you order foods on ifood,
you check on average on
your phone nine times
that the food is going to arrive, right?
These reads are expensive as they run on
relational databases that require lots
of compute requirements.
And this is exactly why Redis
was created by Salvatore.
It's about 16 years ago
and it was created to
accelerate applications.
As a side effect, however,
some users, they thought
they could also reduce
the cost of that relational database.
I'll come back to that later on.
This is the first ChatGPT generated image,
not my favorite.
There's one that comes later on.
So the prompt here is
very straightforward.
So it's a common known problem.
The hot keys is a common known problem,
and everybody knows what it is?
So hot keys happen when keys
are accessed very frequently
or written into very frequently.
Now, there are more
than these two use cases
that I explained here on the
slide that that can happen.
But let's focus on those two today.
Redis, when Salvatore created Redis
he was thinking about throwing away
as many other things
in relational databases
that were not needed and
wanted to make it very simple.
So Redis has a main thread
where all the commands
are executed sequentially
and by minimizing, for example,
the time complexity of
all these operations,
and by being obsessed about
that, you can actually do many,
many operations on a single thread.
Now if you wanna scale it,
if you wanna scale your Redis cluster,
you can have a key space.
You can actually create a Redis cluster.
So you can have many
nodes within a cluster.
But a single key can only
reside in a single chart.
You can do some replication,
but still there are some
limitations of what you can do.
There are two common patterns here.
One is the frequently
accessed keys, which could be,
for example, in case of a social media,
there is an influencer, not me,
whose profile is being
accessed very frequently.
So that could be a hot key.
That is where our high
throughput is going to go
into a single Redis process.
But what we saw when we look into our data
and the cloud, how Redis is
being used, we actually saw
that there was like lots of
usage of sets and sorted sets
and we thought like, "Well, why is that?"
Like, which use cases
are they using that for?
And I dunno if some of the users here
are using Spring Data Redis
and Spring Data Redis,
you can add simple annotations
that say indexed or add index on top
of some of the fields you do.
And then actually that's translating
that into sets and sorted sets.
So you're creating second
re-indexing use cases in Redis.
And what happened then is that
if you wanna do, for example,
you wanna say this field and that field
that will do an intersection in between
those two sets, right?
That also becomes like a heavily
hotkey in your key space.
And hotkeys lasting about that is actually
that it makes your key space imbalanced.
I've been working upon these two problems
and the the first problem,
like the influencer problem,
we've created for that client side caching
and with client side caching,
we'll actually keep a copy
of the hot key within the client library,
within the client application.
So on a repeated consecutive read,
you will just access the data
locally from local memory
and avoiding the network roundtrip.
And this is of course
for great reads, heavy workloads.
We have some customers
that sometimes do one write
and read the same key 50 times.
That's a perfect sweet
spot use case for that.
Redis will track each client
library, for each client,
which keys are being
cached in a local cache,
and then when there's a
write in the Redis database,
we can actually send them in validation
to these client libraries.
It's been around for a while,
but it was not supported by
any of the client libraries.
So we added the support within
all the major client libraries
and it's available
since Redis 7.4 onwards.
So this solves the influencer problem.
For the second indexing,
we created something
that initially was called Redis search.
We now call it the Redis query engine.
And with the Redis query
engine, you can define a schema
and a schema defines which
fields in either hashes or JSON
we will index given also a prefix.
The index doesn't reside in the key space.
And whenever you do a write into the hash
or into the JSON, we
will just automatically
update the index.
And they can access that index.
Now it comes with a coordinator.
So whenever you make a query,
a read query, you will hit one
of the charts, sorry, I say charts,
but the notes in your cluster.
And the coordinator will like
do map reduce operations,
all the processes and we'll
gather the results back.
We've got support for
different field types:
Text for full text search,
Tag for exact matching,
Numeric, Geo and also Vector.
And you can combine in the query,
you can actually combine
the different fields
that you index within an index
to create complex queries.
Now this actually changes,
this is a significant element
in cache modernization
because it unlocks a huge variety
of new use cases that you can do.
One of them could be, for
example, common use cases,
a session store, you put items
in your shopping baskets,
but the shopping basket is a
single hash for all your users.
But now you can ask a question like,
how many users have this particular item
in their shopping basket right now?
This is something you
can now ask to Redis.
Just giving as an example,
but there are many more.
One thing that Redis is
commonly being used for
is a Feature Store, an
online Feature Store where
you retrieve features to serve them
to an AI and machine learning model.
We'll talk about later on more.
But now with this query
engine, you can actually do
the selection of those queries.
So imagine you're a food delivery company
and you would like to
retrieve all the restaurants
that are in a specific radius
from a specific geo point.
You wanna say all the
restaurants that are having a tag
for example, Italian restaurants,
and you wanna retrieve
all these restaurants
and feed them into a
recommendation engine.
Before that, you had to do
like a two phase approach
with some other solution.
Now you can do that in Redis directly.
And this makes sense
because you probably want
to serve those recommendations very fast
and retrieve them from Redis.
The Redis query engine is also powering
our vector search technology.
It enables you to do like blazing fast,
a vector similarity search.
And just for you to know how fast it is,
we actually have a benchmark.
There is a blog post that
we have written about.
And you can also find the code that we use
for benchmarking this on GitHub.
We tried all permutations.
We tried different data sets,
different embedding models,
different vector sizes,
different workloads,
different queries.
Whatever we tried compared
to our competitors,
we came out faster.
We serve the vectors from memory.
So that's the obvious
reason why we can do that.
One of those use cases that
you might be using this vector
search technology for is RAG
and Heber will talk about that later on.
But it also powers a new
product that we're building,
which is called LangCache.
And again, it's kind of like a sweet spot
use case for Redis.
It's called semantic caching.
So semantic caching allows you
to cache responses from an LLM
and then on subsequent similar
or semantically similarly questions
you can return the response
rather than calling your LLM.
And as such, you can of course
increase the performance
or the latency to your
application up to 15 times.
But you can also reduce the cost,
you can avoid calling the expensive LLM.
We've got a solution there
that is served from our cloud.
It has a rest API that you can call.
And you can also use
several embedding models.
We have a support for OpenAI, Anthropic.
But we also have our own model
that is specifically fine
tuned for semantic caching.
Asurion is one of our customers
that is using semantic caching
and they were able to do
a cash hit rate of 70%.
And with that they would actually reduce
the response time in their
customer service portal in half.
They would cut in half and
they would get four times
more engagement on their
customer service portal.
I personally think that
this is a great use case,
a technology fit for Redis, right?
Redis was used for caching.
You can put a time to live
up on top of this response
so you can recalculate
off a specific time.
This is a sweet spot use case.
So it's now available in
public preview if you want
to get access to it,
you can get directly get
access by on redis.io/langcache
You can get started
with the free database.
I'll see the phone coming up.
So I'll leave that on for a while.
I'm going to switch gears and
talk a bit more about caching.
So there are several
known caching patterns.
You've all heard about
Cache-aside, right behind read
through and all these caching patterns.
But the Cache-aside is
like the most common one.
So in a Cache-aside,
I know you all know Redis,
but I still explain it.
You first go to Redis,
when there's a read you check
in Redis, it's not there.
You've got a cache miss.
You will go to your relational
database, execute the query,
put it in Redis, return
to your application.
On a consecutive read,
there will be a cache hit
and you will return the point faster.
And as such you accelerate
your application.
So this is great when part
of your data set is hot,
higher p95 latencies are allowed
because in some cases you
will still have to go to
that relational database
and data is changing slowly.
And notice that
your relational database
is serving all the writes
but it's on your primary database,
but it's still serving
some of the reads, right?
Remember that total cost of ownership.
Note that I made in the beginning
that Redis was supposed to kind
of reduce the total cost of ownership.
And this is not really true
because you still need
to serve the reads from
that relational database.
A common problem with
this, yeah, (chuckles)
I love this one.
There's still a better one. Hang on.
So a common problem with
a cache site is stale data
and stale data can occur of course when
you did the write in
that relation database
and you've put some keys in your cache.
So then at that moment in
time they're out of sync.
So the way you can solve that
in Redis is by putting a time
to live on that key and it will
expire after a certain time.
And then of course there
will be a cache miss
and you will call that data again.
You will, sorry, you'll call
your primary database again.
The problem with this is
that's a bit of a guesswork.
If you put your time to
the very fine grains,
you will have lots of cache misses.
And what was the point of having
your cache in the first place?
If you put it too long,
you look at cumbersome
customer experience.
Imagine for example, you
would put all your order list
or your recently bought
orders into a cache.
As a customer, I buy something, I go
and check the order list, it's not there.
I buy it again, that's quite
a cumbersome experience,
so that might not be an ideal fit.
Now this is my favorite.
Another problem with a cache site is,
anybody wants to guess what
the image on the left is?
So thundering herds, (chuckles)
which ChatGPT took very little literally.
So a thundering herd problem can occur
due to some, in a distributed
system, due to some situation,
all requests will go
into a single resource.
And as such you will overload
that single resource.
It can happen in our social
media and the influencer,
when we put an expiry on the social media.
The key will expire,
all requests into Redis
will be cache misses.
They will go to your relational database.
It can also happen when
you put like a TTL expire
at a specific moment in time.
All the keys with that
specific moment in time,
they'll expire and they will go there.
It can also occur as a cold start
because if you start with
a cache site initially,
the cache is empty and
all your requests will go
to your relational database.
So the source database still
needs to be signed according to
serving all the potential
reads from that database.
Now this a quote from
a seasoned developer.
It helped me, great in
this, in the stock, right?
So Phil Karlton used to work
on Netscape over a decade ago.
And he stated that there
are only two hard things
in computer science: cache
invalidation and naming things.
Now that alums are
basically writing our codes,
we can consider the naming things solved.
So if Redis could solve the
cache validation problem,
then we basically solved all
the computer science problems.
So why is cache validation complex?
The first reason is, is that Redis
is a non transactional database.
So you don't have the concept
of doing something like
a two phase commit in between your writes
and into those two database source.
But that's not the biggest problem.
The problem is that the
application doesn't know
which data points are actually
being cached within Redis.
You might have a single row
and a specific column that
resulted into 20 keys,
cache keys in Redis.
So there's no mapping in between that.
The way we see our
customers solving this is
by using instead of a Cache-aside,
just use a Refresh-ahead.
A refresh-ahead cache
or a prefetch cache is also
a common name for that.
So in that case, you move the data
from your primary data store into Redis.
There's some magic there
happening in the middle.
And then you do have some way
to capture all the new
changes in that database
and to replicate them to Redis.
In this case, all your
writes going to Redis
and all your reads are
being sourced from, sorry,
all your writes going
to your private database
and all your reads are
being sourced from Redis.
You could also see this for the architects
or the computer science
room as CQS, it's a proper,
a common use case of CQS
where you'll model your data
for rights in a specific,
domain specific model
and then you will serve
or translate your data
into Redis data structures,
serving your reads faster.
Of course, this is great when
data is accessed randomly,
you can't have high p95 file latencies.
Data is in flux or higher
data consistency is required.
Now the way we see our
customers doing that
is there are three different ways.
One of our customers is actually,
they have like thousands
of Chrome jobs that move data
from Oracle towards Redis.
It's literally an operational nightmare.
Other ways could be by
using complex architectures,
using Kafka moving data.
But of course it makes, as more components
in your architecture.
Of course ETL tools could
be handy to do that as well.
They can do change data capture,
but ETL tools are typically
made for relational
to relational workloads
and they don't know about
the variety of data searches
that we have in Redis.
And for that we created
Redis data integration.
Redis, or short RDI, it
makes it synchronizing Redis
from any relational database
and soon, any data source,
very straightforward, simple and fast.
And we've built RDI on
proven technologies.
So we're using Apache Flink
and the bees under the hood
and we're adding our expertise
on top of that, on how to
transform data from a relation
or any data source towards the variety
of data structures in Redis.
So RDI actually is a low code solution.
You can upload transformation
logic to towards RDI.
It can allow you to do
some denormalization.
What happens here is that we will first
we will capture the changes
from our initial load
from your data source via CDC collector.
We'll have an intermediate Redis database,
we're using Redis streams for that.
And then there's a second
process, which is a asynchronously
retrieving those items from
those streams is applying your
transformation logic and
then writing it into Redis.
In that transformational
logic, we might also
do lookups into Redis, for
example, for denormalization.
We've got many customers using RDI already
on premise, but Axis Bank is one of those
that is actually using it
for their mobile banking application.
They were originally doing
all their core banking logic
and writing it into Oracle.
And then their mobile
banking app was actually
serving their reads directly
from the same Oracle database.
They have 6 million daily
active mobile banking users.
They were trying to
scale, of course the reads
as an application modernization,
they were adding all
Oracle reads replicas,
but it didn't hit the
throughput that they needed.
So what we did is we added RDI
and together with our risk
query engine that I spoke before
and now the results speaks for themselves.
Before they had like 173 milliseconds
response time at peak time
and now it's 29 milliseconds.
They maxed out at 500 requests per second
that they could do on their
original Oracle database
and now they can do tens of thousands
and they can actually just scale Redis
by adding more notes into the cluster.
So I have a demo for that.
I did do the recording,
so I didn't know I could do a live demo.
But in this demo, it's a recording.
I'll show you some data
in a Postgres database.
We'll spin up RDI in Redis cloud
and we'll show you how
it results into Redis.
And then after us we'll
make a change of course
and hope that the change
ends up being in Redis.
So let's go ahead.
So I'm connected to the Postgres database.
I'm going to show you the
tables that are there.
It's the Chinook data set.
I'm gonna show you one
table, the genre table.
So there are two columns.
There is genre ID and name.
And the first ID is Rock,
which we'll use later on in the talk.
So I already created like a
database and I will go ahead
and connect to that database.
So this is Redis Insight,
the visual developer tool for Redis.
You can see there is no data there,
but I'm live recording.
So I do ping and pong.
Redis is always friendly and answers me.
There's a data pipeline section.
I already set up the initial
setup there with private link.
I can go ahead, I can select some tables.
I will do artist, album, genre.
And right now in the UI I can
only choose to write into Hash
or in JSON, but you can
write in all data structures
and you can also upload
your transformation file.
It gives me a summary
and then I can go ahead
and I can deploy the pipeline.
So we made RDI like
secure from the ground up.
So this will run in your
dedicated environment,
your dedicated RDI cluster together with,
or your dedicated database.
What it first will do, now we deploy this,
it'll do the initial
sync or like hydration.
So it'll retrieve all the data
from the Postgres database.
It's not that much, but the
time it takes mostly here
is to deploy this pipeline actually.
So there we go.
Now it transferred those records.
There are 647 records in total.
And afterwards, once it finalize that,
it will go into streaming mode.
So we got notification,
it's now in streaming mode.
So now it's capturing all the
changes from that database.
We can go ahead and look
again into Redis Insight.
The tables are now there.
We've got genre ID, genre ID 1.
Okay, there's our key rock that is there.
So that doesn't prove still
that we can do changes
that capture and we can
keep on your cache fresh
with any change that comes.
So we'll now do an update
in the Postgres database.
And for that we're going to then use
of course the bees uses the
write headlock from Postgres.
So instead of showing you
within Redis Insight again
what the changed value would
be, I thought to be creative
and I use the Redis MPC server
just to talk a bit about AI
and access the data within Redis.
So I first asked it of course
how many keys there
are within the database
and it knows there's a tool DB size.
Okay, we've got 647
records. So far so good.
Then I was doing this recording
and I really struggled
typing the right question.
I wanted to ask it like,
"Hey, can you retrieve this genre ID
with ID1, and can you tell
me what the value is?"
But I was struggling a
bit, but I thought like,
do I do another recording
or I just leave it as is?
Because it's actually interesting,
it still figures out
correctly what the value is.
So the first thing it'll do like,
well I don't know, it's a key value store.
It's schema-less Redis.
How do I know which
key I need to retrieve?
So it does a bit of scanning.
It's going to scan a couple of keys,
and in those scans you can actually see
that it figures out what genres
and with that it can figure out
what is the key pattern you use.
In Redis you typically
use a colon in the middle
to separate the specific
fields within a key
or to make a hierarchy or like
a nesting, like a tree view.
So it figured out, okay,
what the structure is.
It figured out there are 25 keys.
Great. And this is a structure.
So that's the key that is there.
And I guess it ask me friendly
of course if I can retrieve it.
And still doesn't know
which command to execute
because it could be a hash,
it could be whatever it is.
So it first is going
to figure out the type
and then retrieve that from Redis.
I hope you're going to see
Rock and Roll in the end.
I know we will.
So there we go.
I'm happy to say we're
working upon that in our team.
That Redis data integration
is now in public preview.
You can go ahead and get access to it
by scanning this QR code
or just go to Redis.io/data-integration
For those who who've
been paying attention,
they might have thought like, well,
in a cache site I have like a portion
of my dataset like 20%,
but with this new Redis data integration,
you will move all my data.
And we got a couple of sales reps
in the audience they were like,
"Be very happy about that."
Because it might be that you think
that it's gonna cost me a lot more.
So we thought about that
and when Salvatore created Redis,
like the bandwidth of memory
was about 10,000 megabytes per second.
And nowadays, and Vimy search
is 16,000 megabytes per second.
Like, the architectural principles,
design principles, that that he used
for creating Redis like 15, 16 years ago,
they're no longer valid.
So what we created is
we created Redis Flex
and Redis Flex is auto tiering
for higher scale at lower costs.
So we extend your key space
with a slower storage,
either SSD or NVME.
And so key and values, they
either reside in memory
or they reside on the slower storage.
Of course, we will keep the keys
that you access more frequently into RAM
and the ones that are cold
values are called cold keys.
And cold values will keep
them on the slower storage.
So within Redis cloud
you can actually choose
how much RAM you will
have within your database.
You can configure that
to 90% to be on disk.
You can create databases
up to 50 terabytes.
It starts at 250 gigabytes minimum.
And of course the new pricing is in place
and it reduces the cost
compared to an in-memory days
by up to 75%.
We've got customers like
ifood, Heber will talk about
that later on, of course
using this as well.
And the top use case for
using this is actually
a Feature Store use case.
And if you combine it again
with RDI, we can actually move
and keep that Feature
Store always in sync,
the latest feature that you
have in your primary databases.
One more QR code, there's one more coming.
Redis Flex, since this week
actually generally available
on Redis Cloud.
So one more evolution story is that
as users we're leveraging Redis,
they were actually using
it for more rich use cases.
And this is a beautiful
prompt as well by the way.
But what we saw is that lots
of users, they were actually
serializing Java objects
and writing them into strings
in the strings data structure.
Now that's interesting
because what they needed
was some level of nesting,
they needed like a
hierarchical data structure,
but the only hierarchical
data structure available
in Redis is a hash where we
have like one level of nesting.
So the prompt here was,
draw me an image of JSON
serialized into a string.
There are many things wrong
there, but... (chuckles)
So what is the problem
that we see that our users,
our community actually
doing with this is that
they would like to do, for example,
a small update within an asset document.
But to do that they have to retrieve
the entire serialized object.
Deserialize it, make an update,
serialize it, and write it back.
Meanwhile, somebody else
or some other client might
have updated that key.
So you need to watch that key.
You might need to rewrite
that entire operation.
Another problem is, is
that if you would like
to retrieve some part of your
nest document, you still have
to retrieve the entire document.
And that's not the Redis way.
The Redis way is about
simplicity and about performance.
You only wanna retrieve and send over
the network exactly what you need.
So we created a native
JSON data structure.
There's lots of text on there,
but the main point is that
under the hood it's a binary tree.
And as such with JSON pod, you
can actually do two things.
There are many things you can do,
but the two important ones
to take away from it is
that you can do atomic updates
on a sub path of your documents.
So for example, you can say in this JSON,
there's a MacBook with a quantity of 15.
You can do JSON.inker by,
you can specify the path
of your document and you
say increment it by 3.
This is the Redis way, right?
Rather than having to retrieve
that document client site,
make the change and write it back.
And you can of course also still retrieve
sub parts of that document.
Now we've built this Redis query engine
and this also works of course
with our Redis query engine.
So that makes it very interesting
because we can now index
fields based upon this
JSON path expression.
Users also wanted to use our
vector search capabilities
with this Redis query engine.
The way to model a
vector into JSON is just
by using an array and
you have all the values
of your vector in that array.
The problem with this
initial data structure
that we've created was that
if you would model the same
vector in a JSON data structure,
it would consume seven times
more memory than it would do
into into a hash.
It makes it like very impractical
because it can be way too
expensive to use that.
So it's great that we
have this capability,
but it was not useful for
vector search capabilities.
So what we did is we
actually built a feature
that allows us to compress vectors
and we call it like for homogeneous erase.
So when all the elements in
your JSON are of the same type
or the same elements, you
can actually compress that,
rather than having type, value type value
will now just like compress that.
And for specific vector types,
we can actually reduce
the memory up to 92%.
And that really makes it
like practical because
before that it was like seven times more
and now it's actually even less than hash.
I think this is really interesting
because now we can have model
hierarchical data in Redis
and also add a vector similarity
search on top of that.
Now that's not the only thing
that we've been improving.
We've also focused upon Redis Open Source
and making it incrementally faster.
This is a benchmark that
we did on a mixed workload
and we try to focus upon that.
We try to focus upon
like real life workload,
not like workloads that
are like lab setups tests.
So in this case it's like
10% writes, 90% reads.
We're using four IO threads,
but each key is one kilobyte in size.
And every minor version
that we make there is
actually an increment.
And the latest version 8.4,
we actually crossed to 1 million.
So in a four core box,
on a single main thread Redis process,
you can now do more than
1.25 million operations.
Mixed workload.
And we also wanted to
make it faster of course
for our enterprise customers.
So what we've done is we invested
a lot in our TLS solution.
So when you have a secure connection
with TLS towards our Redis
cloud database, we can easily
deliver two times the performance compared
to ElastiCache on the
same number of VCPUs.
In general Redis the 8.4,
which is the latest release,
is the fastest Redis ever.
It's up to 40% faster in
scaling up and scaling down,
which is particularly
important for our customers,
for example, in events like Black Friday.
We focus a lot upon improving
the latency of each command.
We can now just by upgrading
to 7.4, which was the latest,
the the previous minus
to 8.4, you can get up
to 90% latency improvements
just by upgrading.
I know that the top two there
are hyper log and bitmap,
which you might not be using.
However, for hashes it's
up to 55% and for sets
it sets is up to 70%.
And we also added quantization
into our vector search solution,
which obviously drastically
reduces the size
of the index but also
enables a higher throughput.
And we spoke about the
memory savings before.
There are many more things
that we did in Redis 8.4
and it would just be
like a long enumeration
of small things.
And actually I think they're
all like paper cut fixes.
Sometimes you need to use
two commands, for example,
to add an element into a specific key
and then do an expiry which required you
to do a transaction, et cetera, et cetera.
So there are small things
that we keep on improving
and actually make a better
experience for our developers.
They're made there.
I don't wanna go over the long list,
but we wrote a long blog post about that
with all those changes.
And I'm happy to say that
the Redis 8.4 is now also
generally available for Redis Open Source
and it'll be available
early next year in our cloud
and also for our enterprise
on-premise customers.
I've been talking a lot.
I'm going to summarize, I'm going
to head out over finally
to Heber, gimme one moment.
So the modern cache,
like how this all evolved
from let's say 10 years ago.
We believe that the Redis
query engine is now really
an essential ingredient
in our modern cache stack.
It doesn't only solve like
the hot key problem for
the sets and sorted sets,
but it also powers new use case such
as RAG and semantic caching.
It transforms existing use
cases such as session store
but also Feature Store use cases.
Client side caching of
course solves the hot key,
the other hot key problem.
Whereas data integration,
which is now hosted
allows you to cache data
and keep it always in sync
with your primary data source.
That allows for greater scalability
and it's faster the first time.
And the last thing you need to know
is that we're obsessed by latency.
It's our fastest release
now with Redis 8.4
with the fastest secure cache
and also the fastest effective
database on the planet.
And I highlighted three red things
and these three red things are things
that Heber from ifood
is going to talk about.
So I would welcome him to stage right now.
(audience applauds)
Thank you.
Good luck.
- Thank you Pieter.
So, I want to share you first
of all my three goals here.
My first goal is to
share part of my journey
and some applications that
use Redis Insight, ifood.
And my second goal is to
connect these applications to
what Pieter showed you.
And my third goal is to make
my English clear to you.
So I hope to achieve the first two goals
with my English, right?
First of all, I am from Brazil.
I work with tech for more than 20 years,
probably just shows part of my age.
I'm at ifood for five years.
Today, I work inside a
Gene AI platform team,
which is part of the ML
platform inside ifood.
And part of the examples
that I will show you is
inside this platform team.
Before ifood I worked
with industrial automation
for almost 15 years.
And what connected me
to the data and AI area
was my master degree in computer science.
So I know as I am,
you will probably forget
part of these numbers
in few seconds, this is what I expect.
But what I'm trying to show
you here is that ifood has
more than 160 million orders per month.
And this basically shows which
is the amount of sessions
that we have per day, which
is the amount of users
that are connected using ifood.
Ifood is,
who here knows ifood?
Wow, great.
Who here knows our Redis went to Brazil?
Great, great.
So ifood is known to be the biggest
food delivery company in Latin America.
But it's also a company
with a whole ecosystem,
we don't deliver just food, we deliver
groceries, we also have logistic services
to deliver things to
companies, restaurants,
and other types of merchants.
We have, when we think about
partner establishments,
we have more than 450 establishments.
We are working or running
inside more than 1,500 cities,
different cities in Brazil.
We have connected to the
logistic access ecosystem.
We have more than 450 delivery people.
We have probably more
than 60 different users
using monthly ifood app.
And we call employees
from ifood, food lovers.
We have more than 8,000
food lovers at this moment.
And to connect to the applications
that we will show you,
and this is the message that I want you
to record from this slide.
So we have thousands of
different services running.
When I say different services
are microservices, softwares
that are running and
supporting all these numbers.
We have agents, internal agents,
or agents that interact
with external partners
running inside our infrastructure.
So this is what ifood
representing in Brazil.
And the first application
that I want to show you
or connect to Redis is
what we call internally as GenPlat.
Basically it's Gene AI platform which
connects users and different
services to Gene AI models.
It's basically a way to centralize
the access to the models,
but it also solves governance
and a lot of other challenge.
So the numbers of this platform
is basically 1 trillion tokens per month,
more than 400 million requests per month.
And basically we have at this
moment more than 200 different
services using our platform
to access Gene AI models.
Part of these models are inside AWS,
part of these models are
outside, for example,
we have OpenAI, Gemini,
and we also have some Open
Source models that we train
by ourselves and are running
and making Gene AI inferences
there internally, ifood.
Besides these services
numbers, we also have
more than 500 different users
that uses Gene AI models to create code
and use them to make their
life easier and better.
And where is Redis here?
Redis is basically
the system used to
control the rate limiting.
I think you already know that,
but when we think about the
Gene AI model, you have limits,
you have requests per minute
limits, you have tokens
per minute limit.
And Redis is used inside this platform
to guarantee consistence of this number.
"Oh, I'm a user or I'm a service,
I'm using this specific model
and I need to control this rate limit
and Redis is an excellent
solution to do that.
So the second example that I
want to show here is the RAG
that we have internally.
This is basically, I know
that we are in a agent moment,
but few months ago we were
talking about few months
or probably two years ago, we
starting to talk about RAG.
It's basically a solution
that solves the missing context
from the Gene AI models.
So if you're using an OpenAI
model, if you're using
a Google model or other provider model,
you already know that it
doesn't have your data there.
It wasn't trained using your data.
So the RAG solution basically
solves this problem.
It gives context to the
models to answer things
and to give you the answer
you know, given this context.
So our internal RAG API basically is
split in two important pipelines.
The first pipeline is
the ingestion pipeline
which given a group of documents,
you split them in chunks,
you store them at Redis Vector store.
And then this process is configurable
by services or by projects
there inside ifood.
And then there's a second pipeline,
which is the retrieval pipeline.
During these two pipelines,
we are using different
models through GenPlat API.
The first type of model
is the embedding model,
which basically transforms the text
or the content in a vector of numbers
and stores inside the Vector store.
The second pipeline is the
retrieve and answer thing.
So if you receive a text,
basically first you transform
this text in an embedding
and then you retrieve from
the vector store, which is
inside Redis, the contexts
that are near that text.
And with this near this context,
you deliver it to the
model, to the Gene AI model
to answer your initial question.
So...
the third application
example that I want to share
with you is the Feature Store.
I don't know if everybody
knows here what's
the solution or the pain
that Feature Store solves,
but it's basically delivering
content to make inference.
Inside ifood, before
Gene AI model were used,
we developed a lot of
classical machine learning.
And part of this
classical machine learning
are make inferences to enter things.
For example, give
recommendations of dishes
or other type of products
to users that are connected
to our application.
So when these models are making inference,
they need information, they need inputs,
and these inputs are
stored inside Feature Store
and connected to those sessions, users,
establishments, partners
that I showed you,
we have this type of solution.
Basically you need to make a
recommendation, for example,
to a user sometimes thousands
or millions of users
and you retrieve some
features from that user,
from the Feature Store
and you give it to a classical
machine learning model.
And the output is
basically a recommendation
that can be used there.
So with the Feature
Store, we basically have
two different types of storage solutions.
One is for offline
inference, which basically is
inside our data lake.
And the second one is
to start inside Redis.
So when we want low latency,
when we need to deliver things
to the model, and make inferences below,
let me see here, 10 milliseconds,
we use Redis.
This is basically one
of the best solutions
or best points that Redis
solves there inside ifood.
So this is it.
This platform also delivered
more than 5 million
requests per second.
And this is basically because we use Redis
and we have more than one,
almost 2,000 different features
that are available there.
This is it.
I think we are ready.